Israel's Supreme planning council is set
to approve further expansion of illegal
settlements in the occupied West Bank
nearly 6 000 housing units are likely to
be approved and three illegal outposts
are being formalized under Israeli law
while the Supreme planning councils
holding the meeting in betel it's the
first time such planning has been
deliberated since the far-right Finance
Minister and settler activist bezalel
mosmotridge was put in charge of
settlement policy Abby Fawcett reports
from the occupied West Bank
is born an immeasurable loss in defense
of a small patch of family land
I inherited from my father him from his
father four generations in the family
his son Jameel was killed by Israeli
soldiers in 2021 during protests against
the illegal Israeli Outpost known as
eviatar
all settlements are illegal under
international law outposts like Aviator
are illegal under Israeli law the
government's ejected settlers from the
hilltop in the past
but in 2021 it promised they could
return permanently once Aviator had been
made a formal settlement that now looks
all but certain
they were enlarge a settlement there's
nothing we can do the Arab rulers have
betrayed us we have nothing but Stones
all Israeli governments supported
settlements not only this one
the man now in charge of settlement
decisions is finance minister and
far-right settler activist bizalo
smartridge this was him in Aviator in
April
this place will be bustling with Jewish
life with heads held high proud and who
loved the land and the Bible
Israel is expected to advance thousands
of new settler homes on Monday prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu calls it a
response to terrorism it's also said to
initiate the formalizing of three
outposts close to the illegal settlement
of Ellie near to where a Palestinian
shooting attack killed four Israeli
settlers last week Anna's existing
outposts are being endorsed by this
Israeli government new ones are
springing up at least six built in the
last week amid an outburst of violence
the Palestinian attack was preceded by a
large-scale Israeli raid on the city of
Janine killing seven Palestinians it was
followed by a wave of settler attacks on
Palestinian communities and these
hastily built new outbursts often in
strategic positions between existing
settlements
this is a new danger that threatens the
Palestinian population on their lands
these outposts have also become a launch
pad for gangs of Hilltop use to carry
out their attacks on the Palestinians
and their houses and nearby villages
from 2012 to 2022 the UN says the
settler population grew by more than a
third to over 700 000 but International
pressure and security and legal concerns
had seen some constraints on building
and especially on attempts to formalize
outposts
for Israel's new government accelerated
settlement expansion is a declared
priority and legalizing outposts is
becoming part of the program Harry
Fawcett Al Jazeera in the occupied West
Bank
we've got two teams covering
developments in a moment we're going to
go to neither Ibrahim who's in Bethlehem
overlooking several illegal settlements
first we're going to go to Imran Khan
whose life for user settlement in the
occupied West Bank Imran we're getting
news lines in saying that Israeli media
has apparently is saying that the
officials have approved plans for 5 000
new homes what do we know about this
plan
thank you
well it was to be expected they were
meeting today in Bethel to try and
decide how many of those settlements
they could actually pass some of them
may not have passed due to technical
specifics but politically speaking this
is a very big victory for Bethel
smotridge the Finance Minister now it
used to be a very complicated process to
be able to approve a settlement
expansion uh it was six phases those six
phases took in security considerations
political considerations they even took
in things like who was going to get the
contract to actually build the
settlement expansions and there was also
the Supreme Court involved as well they
simply dispensed with that last week in
a cabinet decision chaired by the Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu they handed
all of those six phases to bedfordville
smotrich who now is almost in total
control and because of that they were
able to approve all of these 5000 and
settlements let me just show you what
that means in the occupied West Bank
where I am so you see those are that's a
an illegal settlement under
international law they're being
constructed uh some buildings are
already up
900 uh new settlement units will be
approved here and there are two types of
settlers there are those who are
economic settlers uh who come here
because the housing is actually quite
cheap the schools are good and they come
here because they want they can afford
to live here rather than places like
Jerusalem or Tel Aviv and then there are
the ideological settlers these are the
people who call the occupied West Bank
Judea and Samaria and they say that this
land was promised to them in the Bible
and they're going to stay here now these
settlements have been built in
increasing number since the 80s but now
they are actually changing the facts on
the ground where I'm stood it's supposed
to be the state of Palestine if the
two-state solution is ever agreed upon
but we when you have settlements like
this in such large number it's very
difficult to get rid of these people
from these permanent places so it
becomes very difficult to negotiate a
state of Palestine and that's what the
Palestinians are really concerned about
but
with bezel smartridge almost in complete
control and approving these 5 000 new
settlements he's got a success he's got
something that he can play uh to the
gallery with his supporters are
predominantly settlers and this is a big
victory for him over the last 25 weeks
or so I think Al Jazeera has been
reporting on those big protests in
Israel Over plans to change the legal
system how much of a priority is
settlement expansion for Israelis
well the the protests in Tel Aviv you
know Saturday night though get about a
hundred thousand people
um are very internal Israeli politics
this is about the threat to democracy
the Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu
whose judicial changes bill is pushing
through and has pushed through they're
not really concerned about the
settlements per se however because of
the way the Supreme Court set up it can
actually stop settlement building and
that is something that they are
concerned about they're concerned about
the idea that you can strip away the
Supreme Court's power now the far right
of the ruling Coalition
national security minister actually says
that the protesters are anti-democratic
that they don't understand what they're
protesting for that the Supreme Court
has far too much power so it's a bit of
an intricate situation
but not many people are concerned about
the actual settlements in the West Bank
they're much more concerned about the
assault on Democracy within Israeli
itself but within that the Supreme Court
uh of course the settlements come into
it Imran thank you very much indeed that
same and I'm talking to us from the
illegal settlement in the occupied by
spank
well Israel has consistently expanded
the number of its illegal settlements
between 1967 and 2022 they're built more
than 290 of them across the occupied
West Bank with an estimated 460 000
settlers living there Israel has also
built several enclaves in Palestinian
neighborhoods in occupied East Jerusalem
where more than 220 000 Israeli settlers
live
the settlements violate international
law and the large number of Israelis who
live there make it difficult to
establish a Palestinian State near
Ibrahim is joining us live now from
Bethlehem in the occupied West Bank how
worrying is all of this going to be for
Palestinians neither
the settlement issue is has been the
issue that Palestinians have been
talking about for years if not decades
they say how can we have as Palestinians
a contiguous state with territorial
continuity when Israel keeps building
settlements what happened is that in so
many numerous times Palestinians have
told the International Community okay
you want us to negotiate on a state on
the 67 borders what have you you can't
have Israel building on the lands that
are going to be part of the future state
of course the latest such uh let's say
commitment from Israel came in March
when Palestinians and Israelis were
meeting in a meeting under the hospital
auspices of the Americans to kind of
bring a calmness to the situation here
in the occupied West Bank and there has
been promises that no new announcements
were made but as you've just reported
we're seeing new illegal settlement
building in units are being announced
I'm standing here in front of one
settlement it is on built on the land of
the city of betsahur here in the
occupied West Bank this started off in
the early 90s as a small settlement and
if you can see now as the it is the case
with so many other settlements they're
becoming sort of like cities with
playgrounds with access to water
infrastructure electricity roads and on
the other side of the fence because you
can see there is an Israeli built fence
here you have Palestinians who are
struggling to get water struggling to
get resources even their access to
Jerusalem Bethlehem is very close to
Jerusalem it has been severed by those
settlements by the separation wall that
has been built by Israel when it comes
to Palestinians they will tell you that
we've given the political process so
many chances and they've failed look
we're losing more lands as we speak so
for that the armed confrontation has
been really the reason or the way for
them to move forward and basically make
the world listen to them need Abraham
talking to us from Bethlehem in the
occupied West Bank neither thank you
very much